di che cosa parliamo quando parliamo di
utopia
cosa vi viene in mente se vi chiedo di
pensare ad un utopia è molto probabile
che state pensando a qualcosa di
assimilabile al concetto di desiderio ma
un desiderio particolare quasi onirico
inconscio il desiderio di raggiungere
qualcosa che sapete vi dà un certo grado
di felicità ma sapete anche che è
irrealizzabile
siete in crisi con la fidanzata con il
fidanzato cercate di pensare ad un nuovo
compagno una nuova compagna un'utopia o
siete lì che mangiate un panino tra una
riunione e l'altra durante una giornata
di lavoro
l'utopia essere magari a bordo piscina
con un piatto davanti del vostro cibo
preferito oppure l'utopia delle utopie
magari realizzarsi personalmente
attraverso un nuovo lavoro o sostituirsi
magari al capo per prendersi qualche
rivincita
poi però se aprono gli occhi e la realtà
l'abbiamo davanti non siamo il capo
stiamo mangiando un panino e la giornata
sta scorrendo davanti ai nostri occhi
queste sono utopie si dice soggettive
personali io ciò di cui voglio parlarvi
oggi non sono le utopie soggettive
perché non ho la bacchetta magica per
esaudire le tutte ma le utopie pubbliche
le utopie che fanno di noi una società
fanno dell'insieme di tutti noi dei
cives dei cittadini e sono molto
distanti da questa concezione di
desiderio irrealizzabile che vi ho
raccontato nella prima parte perché in
realtà quando parliamo di politica di
storia delle idee di storia del pensiero
politico
parliamo di utopie là dove vediamo una
strada per cambiare la nostra società
vediamo una strada irta difficile
vediamo delle cose che non ci piacciono
nella società che stiamo vivendo ma
vogliamo costruire un percorso di
cambiamento costruire un utopia
questo è l'edificio della nuova
fondazione giangiacomo feltrinelli in
viale pasubio a milano inaugurato lo
scorso dicembre
giangiacomo feltrinelli famoso editore
libraio europeo prima di essere un
famoso editore e libraio e stato un
grande collezionista di fonti d'archivio
e di libri tutti dedicati a fotografare
le trasformazioni sociali dal
cinquecento ad oggi qui noi oggi abbiamo
un milione e mezzo di carte d'archivio e
250 mila volumi per parlare dell'utopia
pubblica dell'utopia e del percorso di
trasformazione civile io vi ho portato
un piccolo libricino questo piccolo
libricino e l'edizione del 1643 della
città del sole di tommaso campanella ed
è uno dei pilastri attorno ai quali noi
abbiamo costruito questo edificio è il
progetto di questa casa europea delle
scienze sociali o come ci piace
chiamarlo luogo dell'utopia possibile
questo testo è stato scritto da tommaso
campanella nei 1000 mille e seicento 3
tommaso campanella voleva l'autonomia
della calabria dal regno spagnolo gli
spagnoli non erano molto d'accordo lo
misero in galera lì lui scrisse tutte le
sue opere più importanti di filosofo
politico ricordato che studiato e
collezionato in tutto il mondo ma
naturalmente gli spagnoli non erano mica
tanto contenti di diffondere le sue idee
i suoi scritti questo è un piccolo
libricino in formato super tascabile
prodotto da amici di tommaso campanella
che volevano a tutti i costi nonostante
il divieto da parte degli spagnoli
diffondere il suo pensiero utopico e
importante sia per il contenuto che per
la forma
questo è il frontespizio e questa la
prima pagina vedete civitas solis in
latino è scritto anche quest'altra prima
edizione che è contenuta nei nostri
archivi del the utopia di tommaso moro
1518 qui l'isola dell'utopia e qui
l'alfabeto utopico vi faccio vedere
un'ultima cosa questa è la bandiera
originale della comune di parigi sono
due esempi
tommaso campanella tommaso moro la
comune di parigi
esempi di utopie che sono state
create o che sono state praticate ma
potrei andare avanti montesquieu russo
machiavelli le resistenze europee
le rivoluzioni le controrivoluzioni la
lotta per l'affermazione dei diritti e
qualità diritti dei neri i diritti degli
omosessuali le utopie le stiamo vivendo
ancora oggi lo ius soli e in dibattito
al senato è un'utopia ma come era la
legge sulle unioni civili l'anno scorso
ho ancora il voto per le donne
se andiamo indietro la società è stata
piena di utopia perché ve ne parlo con
tanta enfasi non solo perché quel
progetto è dedicato a rinfocolare la
volontà da parte dei cittadini di
credere in una società diversa e
migliore è la di anche dare un segnale
ai politici e chi ci vuole rappresentare
di infondere fiducia nei confronti dei
cittadini verso una società migliore
me ne parlò proprio perché la qualità
della politica che abbiamo attorno ha
fatto forse un po di passi indietro
rispetto alla centralità delle idee alla
centralità di un progetto appunto un
progetto che può essere assimilabile a
quello che definiamo utopia possibile ma
che invece oggi si perde in tecnicismi
non ha la qualità di quelli che erano i
progetti del novecento e non sono
aggiornati ai linguaggi del 2017 o del
2030 e quindi cosa bisogna fare bisogna
riportare al centro del nostro dibattito
l'esigenza di fondare la politica sulle
idee non solo sulla costruzione di un
progetto sociale sulla individuazione di
priorità con le quali nutrire questo
progetto sociale e le soluzioni che
devono essere protagoniste dei progetti
politici ai quali condivide quali
condividere ai quali attribuire il
nostro voto
in italia questo lo stiamo facendo poco
in giro per il mondo
in realtà ci sono dei personaggi che lo
stanno facendo moltissimo anche con un
certo successo
bernie sanders è stato protagonista
delle scorse elezioni presidenziali
americane delle primarie del partito
democratico facendo una politica che
e stata particolarmente innovativa oltre
partito democratico partito repubblicano
sanders è andato al cuore dei problemi
degli americani in particolare
sostituendo l'obamacare andando a
proporre delle soluzioni in tema
sanitario in tema di sicurezza in tema
di education milioni decine di milioni
di voti e chissà come sarebbe stata la
storia se lui avesse vinto le primarie
avesse fronteggiato donald trump in
europa ci sono degli esempi che di
recente hanno caratterizzato la scena
politica e di fatto hanno riportato la
forza del programma al centro dei
programmi politici jean luc melanchon
addirittura ha creato un nuovo partito
la france in su miss la francia ribelle
chiedendo il voto ai francesi sulla base
di un programma in 100 punti il
programma l'ha chiamato il futuro in
comune la feature share
un futuro in comune fatto di 100 punti
incentrato sul lavoro 4.0 sulla difesa
dei beni comuni
un prodotto di sinistra si direbbe nel
novecento ma lui non lo dice dice è un
prodotto nell'interesse dei cittadini
francesi non ha vinto la diatriba con
emanuel macron maria arrivato quasi al
20 per cento
macron è un altro che afferma tosi
presidente della repubblica francese ha
fondato la sua politica sul ritorno
delle idee ma soprattutto l'idea delle
idee o meglio l'utopia delle utopie cioè
l'europa un grande una grande
affermazione un grande disegno politico
cioè riportare al centro della
geopolitica internazionale dell'europa
chiaramente nella sua visione un pochino
più franco centrica rispetto a quella
germanocentrica che stiamo vivendo oggi
qui abbiamo una donna a da colao sapete
lei è sindaco di barcellona ha imposto
un'altra delle caratteristiche che
dovrebbero così governare i soggetti che
si dedicano la politica cioè la
mediazione a da colao e di podemos è
riuscita la dove molti esponenti
politici spagnoli non sono riusciti a
trovare un punto di equilibrio
partiti tradizionali podemos e gli
indignados e oggi sindaco di barcellona
a dei livelli di popolarità mai
raggiunti in italia ci sono tantissime
situazioni del genere
ve ne cito una da domenico lucano
domenico lucano e il sindaco di riace un
piccolo paese calabro torniamo da
tommaso campanella il paese aerea cioè
negli anni novanta era un piccolo borgo
di quelli che ci ha raccontato marco
magnifico con più di 4 mila abitanti si
è spopolato a molti sono andati in
australia molto sono andati negli stati
uniti in cerca di fortuna a causa della
crisi economica
riace era diventato un borgo di mille
abitanti
ad un certo punto lucano riceve la
telefonata del ministero degli interni
che gli dice abbiamo una nave con 300
migranti
vorremmo attraccare in calabria e
consegnarti queste persone lui invece di
dire no dice si coinvolge i suoi
concittadini riempie le case chiuse
perché appunto gli occupanti erano
emigrati e fa una politica di
integrazione straordinaria nota in tutto
il mondo poco nota in italia che ha
comportato cosa non solo un progetto
sociale innovativo ma anche un nuovo
modello economico per la città è una
grande ripresa turistica da domenico a
riace a tommaso campanella bernie
sanders saint jean luc mélanchon sono
tutte occasioni in cui la politica le
idee e il coraggio il cuore la passione
sono tornate ad essere protagoniste di
un disegno che vuole riportare noi in un
futuro di trasformazione sociale cioè di
conquista dei diritti che non abbiamo di
rivalorizzazione dei diritti che abbiamo
conquistato di futuro possibile
di fatto sono tutti in qualche modo che
hanno percorso una strada una strada
nuova come ci insegna a gianni rodari
il protagonista della sua fiaba ha tre
scelte davanti a sé due strade sono già
state percorse una e invece nessuno ha
avuto il coraggio di percorrerla lui
testa dura
lo chiamano decide di percorrere la
strada che nessuno aveva percorso mai e
anche un po buia quella strada perché va
in mezzo al bosco e non si sa dove porta
e non si vede nemmeno una luce al di là
i suoi amici e lo dissuadono da
percorrere quella strada invece lui dice
no io ci provo
nessuno ha avuto questo coraggio chissà
dove porta allora lui comincia a
intraprendere quella strada arriva nel
bosco il bosco il si apre è un bosco
doloso meraviglioso ma soprattutto vede
una luce al di là del bosco e viene
accolto in una casa enorme bellissima
con una principessa che lo fa entrare
gli regala pietre preziose diamanti
gemme lui riempie un carretto con queste
pietre prezione e ritorna nel suo paese
gli amici dicono ma dove hai preso tutte
queste pietre
ho percorso la strada che voi non
volevate percorrere incominciano a
percorrerlo anche loro perché vogliono
anche loro le gemme ritornano e dicono
ma tu sei un mentitore
lì non c'è più quella quella casa e
quelle gemme e gianni rodari ci dice
certi tesori esistono solo per chi batte
per primo una strada nuova
una strada nuova significa un futuro
nuovo per noi per noi cittadini un
utopia possibile da costruire tutti
assieme per tornare a crederci grazie
[Applauso]